[Music]
well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look at what is on
the front pages it's time to see them
what's making the headlines with harry
cole and pippa creera they will will be
with us right through until midnight uh
welcome to both of you so front pages
then let's start with the daily
telegraph boris johnson will announce a
tax rise to pay for the effect of
lockdown on the nhs the telegraph says
with the prime minister expected to
reveal a hike in national insurance to
fund it that is also the front of the
guardian which says boris johnson will
warn his backbenchers the healthcare
system is in crisis as he tries to head
off a rebellion over his plans well the
daily mail going on the tax rise 2
reporting that employees who earn 30 000
pounds a year will pay roughly 5 pounds
extra a week to bail out the nhs and fix
social care
the times leads with a record number of
migrants crossing the english channel
and pretty patel telling mps she is
ready to withhold millions of pounds
promised to the french to stop them
the education secretary is to look at
making defibrillators mandatory in
schools claimed the mirror after one
father's campaign after his son died of
a cardiac arrest at school
a female estate agent has been awarded a
180 000 payout after her boss refused to
let her leave work early to collect her
child from nursery that's the lead for
the metro and the financial times
reporting that the financial conduct
authority wants action taken to stop
fraudulent or risky crypto investments
being promoted online
so harry cole from the sun paper crew
are from the mirror welcome to both of
you um this is going to be a fascinating
day tomorrow isn't it on tuesday
this very high level news conference
we're expecting on a controversial issue
with the health care service and social
care
wrapped in one harry
well this is quite the first week back
for the government they um after months
and months of pandemic lockdown and
being focused on covid they are ready to
hit the ground running with something
that boris johnson has been telling us
he's gonna he had a plan to fix when he
stood on the steps of downing street
back in july uh 2019 when he first took
over and tomorrow we're finally going to
see this plan um lots of us could be
seeing it for the first time
we have a pretty good idea what's been
agreed the cabinet however astonishingly
have not been given the details on this
they meant to sign this off in about 12
hours time and they're still in the dark
officially as to what's in it but one
thing that's really stuck out in the
last 48 hours or so
is this was always meant to be the big
social care fix that that the prime
minister's been promising but it's been
more and more sort of bled into
actually fixing the nhs backlog and
actually the money that this national
insurance rise of 1.25
uh
for employers and employees um
is actually going to be the first few
years spent on getting the nhs back into
into getting waiting lists down getting
operations back up and running and it's
a big fear tonight amongst conservative
employees and ministers that actually
um in about three years time once the
nhs backlog is fixed is there really
gonna be enough money left to fix the
social care issues as well so there's a
there's a feeling tonight that actually
look the government needed to put up
taxes to pay for the pandemic in their
view and they're dressing this all up
actually as a sort of nhs funding uh a
funding package which is very popular
with voters versus actually what it
meant to be which is for social care so
it'd be interesting to see how they ride
those two horses tomorrow and and pippa
this is exactly what the daily telegraph
is is talking about um calling this tax
rise a sham why not just be honest about
it people will probably quite willingly
pay money towards the nhs towards the
pandemic towards the real problem now of
those waiting lists and tackle social
care separately or is the whole point if
you wrap it together you get social care
under the under the banner of people
being supportive for the nhs
i think there's two things one is the
amount of money it would take not just
to
um to deal with the nhs backlog which uh
any nhs trusts are actually saying that
the the five billion pounds has been
announced to get get um the nhs through
the winter both in terms of dealing with
current virus and starting to make
inroads and that backlog is only half
the amount that's needed so you know if
you're going to not only deal with the
backlog support the nhs to the extent it
needs to be supported and fund the
social care system properly you're
talking a whole lot more money
and then the second aspect of it is of
course that social care and nhs are
irrevocably linked
part of the reason that the the
social care that hospital backlog is
built up is because the social care
provision isn't there in place so you
have people staying in hospital for
longer than they might ordinarily do if
they were able to go into a social care
system that was actually functioning and
i think really the the bottom line of
all of this is that we've had all these
promises from the government and there's
going to be an expectation from social
care providers and from families using
the service that there will be solutions
to some of their problems and that goes
beyond what the government's currently
promising the nhs there are really big
issues around what that reform is going
to look like none of us know that it's
sort of almost gone the car before the
horse and that the government's dealing
with the funding of it before it's
actually got onto the substance of the
type of reforms that need to be need to
be addressed this isn't just about care
homes don't forget that this is about
care the people provided in people's
homes this is about all those uh those
um adults with with um who need support
perhaps with disabilities that aren't
elderly this is about the 16 million
support uh that are unpaid carers as
well and they'll be looking for the
prime minister to give them answers
tomorrow beyond just how the the the
initial package is going to be paid for
yes and certainly the uh the statement
put out by downey street in the last few
minutes uh relates to all those things
you've mentioned the suggestion that the
challenges they say faced by our nhs and
care sector are closely linked a lack of
integration between the current health
and care system these people are often
stuck in the wrong care setting and
families worry about meeting the costs
of care if they leave nhs provision and
many of us with older parents know you
get chucked out of hospital very quickly
because they need the bed for something
else you've got nowhere really to go to
and therefore you start paying for it
yourself don't you harry and this is the
great rub
which relates also back to the dementia
tax accusations against theresa may
where if you're in hospital it's free
and if you're in a care home or a care
setting you pay for it and this is the
great dilemma isn't it for government
yeah so with with the tax rises and also
incidentally with what we think is
coming tomorrow which is another
manifesto commitment about to break the
pensions triple lock which would have
seen pensions five percent wages gone up
so much this year and that's gonna be
broken as well but with that there's
gonna be uh there's gonna be a social
care reform package that will we need to
be legislated on it will need to go
through parliament um no no detail yet
of when it will be implemented but then
crucially there will be that cap we
think it's around 80 000 pounds
which means no one will have to spend
more than that on their social on their
on their social care and the moment down
the street point out that it's twenty
three thousand pounds before you pay in
full for all of your care and lots of
people have you know this is a problem
that's not a new problem it's been
rumbling on for years and years and
years as people lose all of their
savings they lose their houses they lose
the things they want to pass on to
to to their children and then to their
grandchildren now the problem is is
actually is this fix of national
insurance the fairest way to do it
polling shows and you know the treasury
are at pains to point this sort of thing
out that actually national insurance is
the least unpopular tax i got that the
right way around because people do think
rightly well actually wrongly rightly or
wrongly but wrongly in fact that there
is a direct link between what they pay
in national insurance and what they get
back is a very transactional tax in
voters minds so they've sort of gone for
the low-hanging fruit however
it's a tax that disproportionately hits
the poorest people in society the
poorest workers
and it and crucially although they've
paid in all their lives technically
pensioners don't pay it so actually
you're putting up the one tax that pen
that pensioners don't pay in order to
fund pensioners
later years so there's gonna be a big
old route about uh about it i mean
already people like the taxpayers
alliance and labour party i'm suspect
we'll be doing it tomorrow are already
digging up speeches boris johnson gave
when labour pulled this exact trick in
2002 picking up national insurance
rather than income tax because it was
more popular and one boris johnson gave
a very passionate speech in 2002 where
he said it was a tax on jobs a tax
respiration and a tax on the lowest
people in society so expect to hear him
eating his words a little bit tomorrow
and probably from his own from his own
side yeah it could be it could be a
tough news conference couldn't it when
the prime minister the chancellor and
the health secretary will line up can't
wait that's tuesday afternoon we are
told uh you've got a great long list of
things we haven't yet got to so we will
take a break and come back with a lot
more in the next part of our program the
very latest on sausage wars uh eu lorry
drivers and plenty more besides
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me tonight we've got
the political editors from both the sun
and the mirror harry cole and peppa cruz
welcome back to both of you and pippa
let's go to the daily telegraph again
shall we sausage war avoided as uk wins
protocol concession um just uh wrap us
through what the eu has decided then
well david frost our brexit minister has
announced that
the the current status quo basically
um
between uh trade between great britain
and northern ireland is going to
continue for the time being we've had
these grace periods which have meant
that um checks on post-brexit checks
which were planned for certain goods
like chilled goods chilled meats
obviously sausages are the ones which
caught everyone's imagination and thus
it's all being done with sausage wars um
we've had these grace periods that meant
that those checks were not yet put in
place obviously northern ireland
businesses were very concerned about the
impact of of those checks and the latest
grace period was due to end at the end
of september and david foster's
announced that a sort of agreement has
been reached with the european union to
suspend them indefinitely so that they
can have a more constructive environment
for negotiations ultimately what david
frost wants to do is to rip up the
brexit agreement the post-brexit trade
deal that that the the government of the
uk government signed up to with brussels
um and to create one that he regards as
more favorable for for the uk uh whether
that will be successful not i don't know
but what the european union is at least
doing at the moment is not
starting up the legal action that it had
embarked upon before the summer over
this and i think there's a recognition
in european capitals that they want to
take the heat out of the situation
having a sort of a very loud noisy
public battle with boris johnson's
government over this right at the moment
when there's so many other international
issues that they need to work with the
uk on isn't necessarily the way forward
um seems to me that we might end up
being in a position where these talks go
on and on and on as lots of people
predicted when the trade deal was struck
there were still lots of items that were
outstanding and we were likely to see
this still be negotiated in the years to
come okay um harry we're also going to
do uh the labour shortages these eu
drivers in the metro relaxing rules on
eu drivers to ease the shortfall run out
of time but luckily we see you again
very soon